plusieurs mobilisation était organisée
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines contre la
réforme des retraites
amante à poissy ou encore au vésinet
mais le plus grand rassemblement était
ici à versailles plus de 350 personnes
se sont réunies devant la préfecture
pour défiler je suis avec yves de la
cfdt de thales elancourt alors il
pourquoi vous manifester aujourd'hui à
main on manifeste aujourd'hui donc pour
la réforme des retraites
et puis on est présent ici de façon
unitaire
parce que nous semble que c'est
important qu'à un moment on fasse que le
message qui est porté par les syndicats
soient claires et simples pour les
salariés en fait alors la cfdt et on
peut le dire minoritaires ici sur cette
manifestation il ya beaucoup de cgt
est-ce que vous avez est ce que pour
vous c'est important que la cgt soit
représentée dans ce cortège
l'enjeu est supérieur à 1 d ad des
choses des concurrence inter syndicale
qui n'ont aucun intérêt
en parallèle de la réforme des retraites
les syndicats ont également profité pour
défendre certains métiers alors il ya
quelques postiers qui sont ici sur cette
manifestation à versailles pourquoi les
postiers se mobilisent alors les
postiers de versailles se mobilisent
aujourd'hui pour leurs conditions de
travail
ils ont une réorganisation interne qui
se passent mal avec des très très grosse
tournée avec plein de petits problèmes
et qui a cumulé fait que bah c'est plus
possible pour distribuer le courrier en
bonne dans de bonnes conditions
aujourd'hui donc il
ils sont en grève pour montrer à l'heure
et pour renouer le dialogue avec leur
direction pour que les choses
s'arrangent pour qu'ils puissent
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
pour rendre le service aux usagers
parce que aujourd'hui à des problèmes de
distribution de courrier dans versailles
au départ du cortège les manifestants
étaient finalement plus de 600 à défiler
dans les rues versaillaise il ya
beaucoup de monde ça ne sont pas
absolument pas c'est une volonté je
pense d'essayer de venir dans les
vallées dans les chalets bien dans les
sortir un peu de paris pour les
manifestations et ça m'étonne coque et
beaucoup de monde ce qui est vraiment
bon qui sont concernés qui n'ont pas
forcément réussir à aller dans paris
devant l'épreuve de transport est
évidemment donc c'est plutôt bien ça ne
m'étonne pas qu'ils ont tout le monde
que ça je sais matin que la secrétaire
général de la cgt dans les yvelines
sonia porot sonia pour est ce que vous
êtes en est à ce qui est autant pas ici
à verser bas on savait que la colère
était très très fort déjà depuis le 5
décembre mais avoir autant à versailles
c'est exceptionnel ça fait plus jeunes
cette année que ce n'était pas arrivé
quel est le parcours alors on va passer
on est parti de la préfecture ça devant
le château de versailles qui est fermée
puis cela de nombreux grévistes
on va passer devant l' agence régionale
de santé puisque les personnels
hospitaliers sont mobilisés depuis des
mois pour des moyens et pouvoir faire
correctement leur travail
le cortège a terminé son chemin au siège
du medef
ici à versailles à l'heure actuelle
aucune autre manifestation n'est
programmé ici dans la commune